humble et modeste ça fait un point
commun avec les garçons qui sont avec
moi ce matin qui est sûre médiateur qui
son grand frère où on pourrait dire
anges gardiens finalement adelaziz
aboutir comme ça sauvaître termes que
vous préférez entre les trois on va dire
non on va dire le plus plus tôt le grand
frère c'est quoi un grand frère alors
pour vous bah c'est en fait c'est
prendre le relais quoi le relais vers
les jeunes qui sont un peu spécial et
c'est on va dire délaissé oui un peu à
peu à l'abandon en quoi et puis
peut-être de traîné pour le brugeois
vous êtes une épaule pour eux alors là
on voit un contre-exemple à parce que là
c'est une autre génération sur la photo
qui est ici sur l'écran peuvent que vous
savez faire le grand écart en tant que
sportif
abdelaziz tard que vous travaillez dans
un quartier a besoin sont expliqués moi
ou vous êtes aux cartes il de français
ça oui ça sent la couleur celle de
france ça fait cinq ans que je la vends
2 les bruns tous les commerçants sont
quand même content de mon travail
j'espère qu'on voit la photo là à
l'image parce que c'est vrai que trop
peu peur on peut difficilement
comprendre ce qui se passe mais
effectivement là on vous voit discuter
effectivement donc là je suis aussi
en fait mon souci une épaule si pour le
tout ce qui présage et les gens qu'ils
ont besoin de se confier
je lui ai apporté des fois aussi les
courses oui il s'agit donc confident je
suis vraiment je fais un peu tout ça
comment est ce qu'on est venu vous
chercher des nazis qui est venu vous
chercher déjà on peut être un peu de
bouche à oreille aussi un ouais c'est
fait j'en avais marre de devoir les
quartiers de le quartier on explique
c'est ça ils sont les tiens la civilité
et beaucoup d'eau 6 2 bah en fait
comment en fait c'est plus c'est plus sa
femme ainsi le loisir nations qui sont
venu vous chercher là on voit qu'il ya
plusieurs plusieurs commerçants ils sont
dix c'est dommage ils sont pas avec nous
ce matin là il voulait venir et puis
finalement ils sont pas venus et vieux
dommage dommage parce que je suis sûr
qu'ils auraient très bien expliqué ce
pourquoi ils ont fait appel à vous
abdelaziz vous m'arrêtez si je me trompe
je voudrais pas trahir votre pensée mais
on va pas se le cacher tous les trois
abdelaziz ismaël votre remplaçant on va
pas se le cacher au départ y avait des
incivilités ça veut dire des problèmes
oui pour parler clair on va être très
diplomatique ce matin et sans lui on va
les chercher un grand frère quelqu'un du
quartier pour essayer de faire en sorte
que la mayonnaise prenne c'est ça ça a
peu ça aurait alors quel est votre
secret pour que ça fonctionne
mon secret en fait j'en ai pas c'est
plus c'est ce que vous dégagez c'est
naturel en fait ça va ça vient
naturellement j'ai grandi donc à pas
j'ai réussi j'ai beaucoup ri pompage sur
respectueux respecte et je respecte
beaucoup les gens donc il ya un mur en
fait il me rapprochais qu'avec avec les
jeunes
on va discuter l'ajustement rue allard
donc il ya le mur approche moi je me
rapprochais chat c'est à dire que comme
j'ai grandi dans le quartier
donc je quand même oui vous les
connaissez tous sont alors vous les avez
vus grandir mais moi j'aime pas la
recette en fait de résultats
mais voilà c'est ça vient naturellement
décontracté je trouve les mots avec les
jeunes on avéré l'exemple juste avant
avec les moins jeunes on va dire
et puis l'exemple avec les plus jeunes à
chaque fois on sent qu'il ya du dialogue
comme la situation il ya un scooter ou
dans la galerie donc dans mon intérêt
dit quoi mais présager et des poussées
des enfants on a donc j'évite aussi de
ce qui est deux roues à moteur pour dans
la galerie tout ce qu'il ya vu un
scooter rassurant centre commercial
ça se peut voilà faire toucher quelqu'un
à faire voilà et puis c'est un terreau
des pourquoi c'est interdit c'est pour
justement pour cent même pour leur
propre sécurité du jeune fille en est le
centre commercial ccc fréquenter les
gens elle passe dans le centre
commercial il faut pas qu'il ya des
scooters qui voilà qui roule sur le
champ de abdelaziz mais là on a eu deux
exemples de photos où ça se passe bien
regardez moi dans les yeux ça se passe
toujours bien s'il faut dire ça se passe
toujours bien c'est moins turin à la non
mais dites moi mais risque zéro on danse
ou moins de temps de temps en temps
quelques problèmes qu'il faut pas rêver
abdelaziz dit intervention musclée ça
veut dire quoi des fois il ya des
tensions poésie perron de badar
spécialement le jaune à sa place et des
sculptures monde des ivrognes à l'époque
y avait beaucoup de gens qui buvait
canettes de bière
parce qu'on se focalise sur les jeunes
ayant bac c'est une génération difficile
relancer mais c'est en général un délit
jeunes mais c'est c'est-à-dire peut
avoir aussi des personnes à 40 ans va
lui verser 10 n'y a pas que les jeunes
en cdd
ouais je la vois là vous verrez aussi le
confie croit on va être clair si vous
n'êtes pas policier mais vous faites les
flics quoi finalement c'est ça un peu à
peu près c'est à dire embarras à prendre
la place des policiers on en a besoin
aussi font leur travail aussi les
policiers parce qu'on fait pas le même
métier médiateur c'est celle approche de
médiateurs et la proche de policier
c'est pas le même est-ce que selon vous
vous êtes devenu indispensable est ce
que ça suffit finalement votre seule
présence à désamorcer les tensions
on va dire pour l'instant ça réussit
voilà du résultat ce sens en semaine bah
ça réussit pour l'instant il ya de
résultats communauté aziz moi je le vois
c'est vraiment ces mêmes l'on va dire
les gens ils ont pris l'habitude de nous
voir même des personnes qui demandent
après analyse quand je tends
remplacement de temps en temps elle est
où le le barbu au musée et légendes
voilà les jaunes sont pris l'habitude de
le voir et puis maintenant ils ont pris
la voie sur 2 3 ont pris l'habitude de
me voir le remplacer c'est à dire on en
a besoin d'un des médiateurs des deux
centres commerciaux comme ça des cités
on a des grands frères on va dire c'est
comme un grand frère ce qu'on disait
elle se respecte et on fait pas les gros
bras joue pas les gros bras d'ailleurs
la violence comme on le disait tout à
l'heure vous fédérez aussi un petit peu
avec la boxe
vous avez d'autres idées pour intéresser
les jeunes par l'occasion je salue
radouane oublie casse le coach c'est un
ami à moins de réalisme voilà qu'on fait
de la boxe anglaise
j'entraîne aussi - le kick boxing et
pelleter qu 1,2 g 3e dan teclaw avec la
boxe on ramène des jeunes ou dans la
salle de boxe là et puis ça peut aider
quand on fait la boxe déjà rien que le
fait de table sur un ca qu'on l'enlève
l'agressivité ce que je disais j'ai
envie de vous montrer à un autre exemple
de paris soutenue finalement pour que le
vivre ensemble fonctionne vous c'est la
boxe
cette fois ci c soulignée par la
solidarité de versoise dans un film qui
a réalisé son budget voilà c'est un
projet qui réunit des nivernais de 12 à
86 ans ils sont tous amateurs nous
sommes allés sur le tournage
regardez et puis nous revenons ensemble
dans le quartier de la planoise et puis
nous parlerons aussi du divorce avec un
notaire ils représenteront la carotte du
doubs moteur action
c'est l'histoire de nora élevé en
famille d'accueil à nevers et du lien
fort qu'elle tisse avec son frère
l'adoption une jeune africaine étudiante
studieuse un gamin du coin qui
collectionne les délits un récit dont
l'écriture a commencé il ya déjà un an
un projet fou initié par l'enthousiasmé
d'un groupe d'amateurs est ficelé par un
duo tonitruant et à peu près une
vingtaine de scénaristes des jeunes des
vieux ce qu'ont voulu écrire
on a testé les scènes de sur le théâtre
on a fait un va et vient entre
l'écriture et la scène théâtrale pour
s'approcher au plus près d'un scénario
qui tienne la route rue au départ les
jeunes il doit me rattrape pas que les
vieux et vieux qui se méfiait étaient
méfiants à l'égard des jeunes et
maintenant c'est une vraie bande de deux
comédiens alors il est habillé
maintenant ils échangent et la colle à
la costumière 1er junior bien plus d'un
an de collaboration et de partage pour
donner corps et ce long métrage une
passion pour certains une vocation pour
d'autres pour moi c'est une expérience
professionnelle parce que j'aimerais
bien taxés cinéma du coup pour moi c'est
que du bénef en fait encore plus d'un
week end vers bon fond parce que je n'ai
rien et surtout en terme de cinéma donc
pour moi c'est une grande chance parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui aimeraient
bien
ma place plus d'une cinquantaine de
bénévoles entre 12 et 86 ans se sont
investis acteurs mais aussi régisseur
costumière maquilleuse les associations
qui deviennent parfois des amitiés un
soupçon c'était plus riches
générationnel et pluriculturelle donc on
a côtoyé des jeunes qu'on n'aurait pas
eu l'habitude enfin le l'occasion de
côtoyer autrement qu'à travers ce film
les matins on a le plaisir de les
rencontrer dès fois sur les marchés et
viennent nous saluer nous faire lui la
bise
si le tournage touche à sa fin il reste
encore de longs mois de travail première
projection prévue en mars 2019 et
l'équipe recherche encore des diffuseurs
il n'y a pas que nos vins ont fait des
choses positives vous ne le montrez ce
matin ils se mêlent et vous abdelaziz
planoise on peut dire que c'est c'est un
beau quartier on peut y faire des choses
positives l'avenir vous le voyez comment
finalement positif au positif je pense
que le savoir plus évolué dans le bon
sens se pose